Game of Thrones Season 8 Episode 1 is called
Winterfell – and it sets up the conflicts
and mysteries for the final season.
The Thrones title sequence has had an update.
This astrolabe thingy used to show old historical
events – the Doom of Valyria, and Robert’s
Rebellion.
But now it shows recent events.
This shot shows the dragon Viserion breaking
the Wall last season.
You can see the army of the dead watching,
and Bran’s ravens overhead.
This next scene shows the Red Wedding.
The direwolf head is for Robb Stark, killed
by the flayed man of Bolton.
There’s also the Lannister lion, Tully fish,
and Frey castle.
This last shot shows a comet and a dragon
with three smaller dragons.
That’s Daenerys Targaryen hatching her three
dragons in Season 1, beneath the red comet.
So together, these opening shots sum up the
last seven seasons of Thrones – in ice and
blood and fire.
It gives a sense that history is happening.
These wars with Daenerys and Starks and white
walkers – the maesters’ll write books
about them one day – if anyone survives
the walkers.
The episode’s set in three places – Winterfell,
King’s Landing, and Last Hearth.
King Jon and Queen Daenerys arrive at Winterfell
– just like Season 1 Episode 1 had King
Robert and Queen Cersei coming to Winterfell.
A young boy climbs up to get a good view,
just like Bran and Arya did in Season 1 – so
there are lots of callbacks this episode.
Tyrion and Varys talk about balls – there’s
been a lot of talk of balls and butts and
dicks ever since the tv show ran out of books
to adapt.
Season 8 is all new material, so not even
the book nerds know what’s coming.
The people of the north look on Daenerys with
suspicion . Some see her as an invader, with
a foreign army of eunuchs and “savages”
– Grey Worm and Missandei feel a long way
from home.
The northmen also remember Daenerys’ father
the Mad King, who killed the old Starks twenty
years ago.
So Daenerys needs to prove herself to the
north.
Her dragons fly overhead, terrifying the northerners,
and Daenerys looks smug.
Like Tyrion once said, Daenerys needs to scare
people a bit to be taken seriously as a ruler.
But if she relies totally on fear, she’s
no better than her tyrannical father . Jon
warmly reunites with Bran, he says Bran’s
a man now, like he’s all grown up, and Bran
says “Almost” . Because Bran isn’t quite
Bran any more, he’s become the three-eyed
raven, a magical consciousness of the old
gods that gives him visions and powers – and
the raven is not “entirely human” . Bran
acts weird this episode, with lots of ominous
stares.
It may be that because of Bran’s visions,
he knows everything that’s gonna happen,
and he’s guiding everyone along a pre-destined
path, even though he knows there’s tragedy
along the way.
That’s kinda what the original three-eyed
raven did.
In the books, he’s called Bloodraven, and
he does terrible things for the sake of prophecy
and the greater good – go watch that video.
So the point is that Bran’s magic is powerful,
but it comes at a cost.
There’s a big meeting, and there’s tension
between Jon Sansa and Daenerys – cause it’s
not clear who’s in charge . Sansa is the
Lady of Winterfell – she’s been here running
things while Jon was off fighting zombies
and rooting his aunt.
Jon is King in the North, but he gave up his
crown by kneeling to Daenerys.
The northern lords chose Jon because they
want a strong independent north – if Jon
hands the north to a foreign queen, they’re
not gonna support him . Jon and Tyrion argue
that the titles and crowns don’t matter
– the white walker apocalypse is coming,
and they need Daenerys to survive . Tyrion
says that Cersei’s army is coming to help
as well, but the northerners hate the Lannisters
cause they just fought a war against them.
And Sansa points out there’s not enough
food for everyone – not much point surviving
the zombies if everybody starves.
So at Winterfell, the forces of ice and fire
and Lannisters are coming together, and they
don’t get along – but they need each other
to survive.
Tyrion and Sansa reunite.
They were married for a while, until Joffrey
died and Sansa ran off, leaving Tyrion to
be accused of Joffrey’s murder.
Sansa apologises for leaving him hanging – but
they’ve both survived.
Sansa thinks Tyrion’s an idiot for believing
that Cersei would help them – cause of course,
Cersei is actually planning to betray everyone
– she tricked Tyrion.
Tyrion used to have all the best strategies
– but he’s made a lot of bad mistakes
lately.
In Season 6, his peace deal in Meereen failed.
In Season 7, his war plans failed.
And now his supposed alliance with Cersei
will fail.
Tyrion's identity and self-worth are built
on his smart political plays.
So if he continues to fail, who is he?
Arya and Jon finally reunite, after seven
seasons apart.
They were close growing up, because they were
both misfits at Winterfell – Jon as a bastard,
and Arya as a tomboy.
Jon gave Arya her sword, Needle, and he asks
if she’s used it, but she avoids the question
– she’s doesn’t like to talk about the
traumatic stuff she’s been through.
Though Jon mentions that he was killed then
resurrected – which you’d really think
people would talk about more often.
Jon tries to badmouth Sansa – he and Arya
used to gang up on their perfect sister when
they were young.
But Arya and Sansa bonded last season, and
Arya stands up for her sister.
Cause “the lone wolf dies, but the pack
survives” – the Starks have to stick together
. Which is gonna get tricky for Jon – he’s
about to find out that he’s half Stark,
half Targaryen – will he still be a part
of the Stark pack?
Davos suggests that Daenerys and Jon should
get married , which would make a lot of sense.
It could help the northmen accept Daenerys.
It would unite Jon and Dany’s claims to
the Throne.
And conveniently enough, Jon and Dany are
in love.
But Varys gives an ominous warning – he
says that “Nothing lasts” .
Daenerys and Jon go visit the dragons, who
aren’t doing well in the north – these
are creatures of fire in a land of ice.
In Game of Thrones history, there was once
a Targaryen queen who flew her dragon to the
Wall.
And the dragon refused to fly beyond the Wall,
which disturbed the queen . It’s like there’s
something in the north that scares dragons
– probably the white walkers.
Daenerys and Jon have a cute dragon ride.
Jon rides the dragon Rhaegal, who’s named
after his real father, Rhaegar – Daenerys’
brother.
In the lore, only Targaryens have the special
blood to ride dragons – so the fact that
Jon can ride should tip Dany off to Jon’s
real identity.
Dany and Jon make out by a waterfall, which
is a callback to Jon and Ygritte making love
in a cave with a waterfall.
Ygritte said she wanted to stay in the cave
forever , and now Dany says she and Jon “could
stay a thousand years”, but as Varys said,
“Nothing lasts” . Jon and Dany’s love
seems star-crossed – doomed to end in tragedy,
just like Jon and Ygritte.
There are theories about Jon becoming a new
Night King, doomed to protect the realm as
a white walker person forever.
And Daenerys once had vision of leaving the
Throne, and being with her dead love Drogo.
So Jon and Dany probably won’t last – they
might get a different kind of forever.
At Winterfell, Gendry makes weapons of dragonglass,
or obsidian – a volcanic rock that can kill
white walkers.
Gendry gives the Hound a sweet dragonglass
axe, and the Hound reunites with Arya.
Last time they saw each other, Arya left the
Hound for dead.
They get pretty aggressive with each other
– which is just their way of showing their
love.
Arya reunites with Gendry, and he calls her
“my lady”, calling back to his teasing
in Season 2.
In the books, it’s said that “Arya has
the hands of a blacksmith” , and some fans
wonder if Arya might have Gendry’s hand
in marriage – Arya could become Gendry’s
“lady”.
But Arya is not lady-like – she asks Gendry
to make her a weapon , which looks like a
detachable staff with dragonglass at each
end.
We saw her using this weapon in the trailer
– the Faceless Men trained her to fight
with staffs.
Sansa tells Jon that a northern lord, Robett
Glover, is refusing to help the Starks, because
Jon gave up his crown . So this proves Sansa’s
point – Jon’s submission to Dany has made
their family less powerful.
Of course, Jon is also right that Daenerys’
dragons are needed to stop the white walkers.
But Sansa points out that Jon’s relationship
with Dany is not purely political.
He loves her, and that could be a problem,
cause as Aemon once said, “Love is the death
of duty” – Jon might find it difficult
to do things that are good for the realm,
but not good for Daenerys – like if, say,
Jon has to sacrifice Daenerys to save the
world.
Jon and Dany’s arcs are all about balancing
their loves and loyalties against big political
and magical forces.
In the endgame, will they choose love or duty?
Daenerys and Jorah visit Sam.
Daenerys thanks him for curing Jorah’s embarrassing
skin disease last season.
But then Sam finds out that Daenerys killed
Sam’s father and brother, because they wouldn’t
submit to her.
Sam’s dad was a cunt, but Sam loved his
brother.
So Sam is filled with grief and anger at Daenerys.
And Bran chooses that moment to get Sam to
tell Jon the big secret of his parentage.
Jon’s down in the crypts, by the statue
of Ned Stark – the man who Jon thinks is
his father.
But Sam tells him the truth.
Jon is the son of Ned’s sister, Lyanna.
And Jon’s father is Rhaegar Targaryen, Daenerys’
eldest brother.
Jon’s real name is Aegon Targaryen, and
he’s the rightful King of Westeros , ahead
of Daenerys.
So this changes a lot for Jon personally.
Turns out Jon was never a bastard.
The man who raised him isn’t his father.
And his girlfriend Daenerys is actually his
aunt.
Sam pushes the political angle.
He says that by law, Jon is King of Westeros,
and Daenerys shouldn’t be queen . Could
this start a rivalry between Jon and Daenerys,
fighting for the Throne?
Jon doesn’t want be King of Westeros – but
it wouldn’t be the first time he’s reluctantly
accepted power.
Sam asks if Daenerys would ever give up her
crown.
Would she sacrifice the Throne that she’s
been fighting for all this time?
The answer is probably yes – we saw that
vision in Season 2 of Daenerys turning away
from the Throne – Jon and Daenerys may sacrifice
what they desire most.
Jaime Lannister arrives at Winterfell, looking
a lot less blonde than on his last visit.
And Jaime sees Bran.
Last time they met, Jaime pushed Bran from
a tower – crippling him and beginning his
journey to become a psychic tree-wizard.
How will Bran react to Jaime?
Maybe he’ll be distant and indifferent like
was seeing Jon again.
But maybe not.
Cause after Bran’s fall, he didn’t remember
Jaime pushing him.
In the books, the three-eyed raven specifically
deletes that memory from Bran’s head.
Maybe seeing Jaime again will remind Bran
of his fall, and of the boy he used to be.
This also is a danger to Jaime.
If the Starks find out that Jaime crippled
Bran – as well as killing Daenerys’ father
– Jaime might get a warmer welcome to Winterfell
than he’d like.
So this is more tension and drama to distract
from the real war between the living and the
dead.
Down in King’s Landing, Cersei learns that
the Wall has fallen – now, there’s nothing
between Westeros and the white walkers.
And Cersei is happy about this . She figures
that the walkers will kill Daenerys and Jon,
so it’ll be easier for her to hold the Throne
– Cersei is so psychopathic that she welcomes
the zombie apocalypse.
To help her hold power, Euron Greyjoy brings
her Harry Strickland, and his mercenary army,
the Golden Company.
Cersei is mad that the Company didn’t bring
war elephants.
It’s weird that the show even mentions the
elephants if we’re not gonna see any – maybe
the effects budget ran out and they’re just
making a joke of it.
Or maybe the elephants will come later.
The Golden Company has a complex history in
the lore which is probably not relevant to
the show, but the Company has famously never
broken a contract . So maybe, for the first
time, the Company will break contract, and
betray Cersei – maybe she’ll end up on
the wrong end of an elephant.
Cersei has sex with Euron – he asks it as
a condition of their alliance, but she might
have some actual attraction to his arrogance
and recklessness – Euron’s kinda like
Jaime was before he got all honourable, and
Cersei tends to choose lovers who remind her
of her brother.
Cersei cheats on Jaime with several men in
the books , but Jaime has only ever slept
with her.
Euron says that he’ll get Cersei pregnant
, and she has an emotional reaction.
Supposedly, Cersei is already pregnant with
Jaime’s child.
That’s why she didn’t drink wine last
season, and how she convinced Tyrion she’d
help the north.
But now she is drinking wine, and she’s
upset at the mention of pregnancy.
So maybe Cersei has lost her child by miscarriage.
Or maybe she is still pregnant, and she’s
gonna claim that Jaime’s child is Euron’s.
Or maybe she was never pregnant.
Cersei once said that a woman’s weapon is
between her legs – she uses sex and her
body to manipulate people.
Bronn enjoys the company of some prostitutes.
He brags about having shot a dragon last season.
And the women talk about soldiers they know
who’ve been hurt.
They mention a ginger named Eddie, which is
a reference to Ed Sheeran’s cameo last season.
Apparently, Dany’s dragon burned his eyelids
off . And Eddie was a nice guy – Arya made
friends with him.
So this is a reminder of the human cost of
this war – it’s hurting good innocent
people and English singer-songwriters.
Bronn is interrupted by Qyburn.
He says that Cersei will pay Bronn lots of
gold to kill Jaime and Tyrion – using the
crossbow that Tyrion used to kill their father
Tywin.
Cersei has wanted Tyrion dead for years, but
this is the first time she’s moved against
Jaime.
Jaime is her twin, he’s all she’s got
left . Wanting him dead shows how far gone
Cersei is.
Maybe the reason Cersei was emotional earlier
was because she’s ordered the death of the
father of her unborn child.
So what will Bronn do?
Bronn always said he’s just in it for himself,
and he’ll kill anyone for the right price
. But Bronn has been through a lot with Tyrion
and Jaime – will he kill his friends , just
cause the queen told him to?
It’s like Varys’ riddle in Season 2 – who
really holds power?
The man with the sword, or the queen with
the crown?
Maybe Bronn will discover that the real power
is friendship .
Yara Greyjoy is a prisoner of her uncle Euron.
And Euron’s a good host compared to the
books.
In a sample chapter for the upcoming book,
Euron imprisons his brother Aeron.
He chains him naked to a wall, and drugs him
so he has feverish nightmares of apocalypse.
He mocks Aeron’s god , and torments him
over childhood sex abuse . He hangs mutilated
priests from the walls, including a crazed
warlock with his legs cut off . He gets a
woman pregnant, then rips out her tongue,
and ties her and Aeron to the front of his
ship, as part of a mass blood sacrifice to
make Euron into an eldritch god – so, yeah
the Game of Thrones books are gnarly, and
Euron in the show is a Disney pirate in comparison.
While Euron is rooting the queen, his nephew
Theon boards his ship and kills the crew – including
Mac from It’s Always Sunny.
Euron’s ship is called the Silence, cause
he’s removed the tongues of his crew.
As it turns out, mutes don’t make very good
guards.
Theon rescues his sister Yara, and she headbutts
him, as payback for leaving her with Euron
in the first place.
Yara had once tried to rescue Theon from Ramsay
– now Theon has returned the favour.
Yara heads home to the Iron Islands, while
Theon heads to help the Starks . Theon had
once betrayed the Starks, so now he’s trying
to make amends, to redeem his crimes and failures
one by one.
He’s still a traumatised broken man, but
“What is dead may never die” , and Theon
can still do some good.
Far in the north, Last Hearth is the closest
castle to the Wall.
This is the home of young Ned Umber – Sansa
sent him up there to bring his people to safety.
But he was too late – the white walkers
came and killed everyone – raising the dead
as wights and marching them south.
Remember that white walkers are the ice demons,
and wights are the zombies – they’re different.
Beric Edd and Tormund meet at Last Hearth.
The Night’s Watch and wildlings were enemies
for thousands of years – but now they’re
allies and friends.
They find the walkers have left a “message”
– Ned Umber is pinned to a wall in a spiral
of corpses.
Ned comes back as a wight, so Beric burns
him.
The walkers have made corpse-spirals before.
Cause the spiral was a symbol of the children
of the forest – the children created the
Night King, the first white walker, at a tree
with this spiral shape.
So now the Night King is recreating this spiral
as a sort of blasphemy against his creators.
That’s what the writer of this episode said,
anyway . So it seems like the Night King is
angry at his creators, like Frankenstein’s
monster.
He never asked to be made into an ice demon.
So now he wants to punish the world for making
him what he is.
This spiral represents his hate.
And the burning spiral could represent the
fiery magic sacrifice needed to defeat him.
So in Episode 1, the white walkers are marching
their army of the dead towards Winterfell.
But the living are still divided, in drama
between Starks Targaryens and Lannisters.
The situation looks grim, but there is hope.
When Jon learns his true parentage in the
crypts, this might fulfil a prophecy.
Melisandre believes that the prince that was
promised, or Azor Ahai, will defeat the white
walkers.
And the prophecy in the books goes deeper
– here’s a clip from the audiobook – “When
the red star bleeds and the darkness gathers,
Azor Ahai shall be born again amidst smoke
and salt to wake dragons out of stone” . Azor
Ahai will wake dragons from stone.
One interpretation of this is when Daenerys
hatches dragon eggs that were thought to be
petrified, turned to stone.
But another interpretation is that after Jon
learns his Targaryen parentage, in the stone
crypts, he’ll become a metaphorical dragon
– a fiery Targaryen king.
Jon has also been born again, and the red
star connects to the red comet.
So there are a heaps of cool details like
this in the Game of Thrones books – prophecies,
mysteries, whole plotlines and characters
that aren’t in the tv show.
And it’s easy to listen to Thrones on audiobook
while you’re in the car, or the train, or
on dragonback.
You can get a Game of Thrones audiobook free
today, by signing up for a trial with Audible.
Members get a book each month, and if you
cancel, you keep the books.
Sign up at audible.com/asx.
Thanks for watching.
We’re holding Q&A livestreams right after
each episode of Thrones, at about 10pm Eastern
Time.
Thank you to the Patrons, including Peter
Meehan, Olaf Emmerich, Jemima Vivian, Jamie
Moore, Tim Cunniff, Eileen Clark, Riku Aleksi
Heinola, Gabrielle, and Cynicjon, cheers.